I started recognizing countless
experiences of men behaving poorly
inappropriately Sarah Jessica Parker is
getting candid about a me-too moment she
had in the workplace in an interview
with NPR's fresh air the 54 year old
actress were calls her own experience
with harassment in the industry
including one with a quote big movie
star the nature of the person who I felt
was really the instigator though you
know this was a grown man a very a big
big movie star and you know he was baked
meaning his personality it was cooked
and he was a formed person and that
wasn't gonna change Parker did not name
the actor or specify the project she was
working on at the time but she says she
called her agent to help resolve the
issue they felt I was no longer able to
convey how uncomfortable this was making
me how inappropriate was and also that
it was crossing lines outside of this
personal exchange I called my agent
within hours everything had changed he
said to them if this continues I have
sent her a ticket a one-way ticket out
of this city where I was shooting and
she will not be returning parker
continued describing what it was like to
return to set after her agent intervened
it wasn't perfectly Pleasant but I
didn't have to be coy any longer and I
didn't have to dread a potential
conversation I didn't have to listen to
jokes about me or my figure or what
people thought they could talk me into
doing all these men all these men and
that just it that stopped the former Sex
in the City star explained that she
hadn't even thought about all the times
her male co-stars behaved badly until
she read about the scandal
balding disgraced movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein but it really wasn't I would
say until about six or eight months ago
that I started recognizing all the ways
that I had made it possible to keep
coming to work or to remain on set or to
simply as I've described it just push it
down push it away find a little space
for it and move on Parker also admitted
that even when she was a bigger star she
hesitated when it came to putting a stop
to bad behavior I think no matter how
evolved or how modern I thought I was I
didn't feel as powerful as the man who
was behaving inappropriately which is
just strikes me as just stunning to say
out loud
et spoke with SJP about the me2 movement
in 2018 it's extremely exciting to see
this this rollout happen with such I
don't know with such vigor and
enthusiasm and excitement and I think
genuine optimism about what this
endeavor promises I think it's um it's
very exciting and it and it feels like
like a real muscular commitment by
people and I'm extremely optimistic
[Music]